fun James Harden and Marcus Smart
combine their shacking powers for a flop
Jimmy and a brick in one play
oh my goodness
she Mitchell New York City if you're
gonna see me you can't shoot the air
ball
oon
not the first time a Michigan
[Applause]
teams at Christmas don't Chris Weber
come on stop it
that has nothing to do with
It
Meek Mill what more Courtside trip that
gave me flashback come on man he's so
close he could trip a referee yes oh my
gosh
oh come on he did that on purpose
in a movie
that oh oh yeah that was a funny episode
remembers that's one of the best shows
ever oh man
D'Angelo Russell sometimes you check in
other times get checked out
I saw this game he's supposed to be on
the court Kenny
and didn't realize he was on the floor
yes and for how long the whole damn
possession oh man that's a fine got back
there in time to watch the Three Bears
that's a five yeah you probably you
should probably score one five against
four sometimes
Houston Rockets held a two-minute Shaq
and dunk contest in Chuck's favorite
City come on man one minute later come
on
good morning
oh
oh for two Kyle kuzma oh Chuck what do
you think of this outfit from the cruise
are you serious right now I like it I
can't say what that look like that's
okay wearing an airbag
come on man Chuck you got to get one of
those yeah okay you didn't like that one
either got some stuff it's just trying
too hard man
[Music]
Kyle looked away from his shot like
kitty looks away from work
she might ever do that I was doing that
when I was 16. I started that all right
that makes soccer players proud
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
that tree gave a little bit that was
that trees
that's anchored in
oh no number two Jalen green name a more
iconic Duo than the Houston guard and
shacked in the pool oh go get it oh oh
my goodness go get it
and he's a dunk contest guy yo come on
Kenny Martin Junior go get that
baby first Chuck they had too many
cheers before the game no they did Jimmy
let me get some of that Spanish music
[Music]
[Laughter]
number one Ivanka zubach take center
stage and become the star of the show
go get it get it
he's like they might start
the number two Joel and B continue the
trend of big men getting stuck in dance
routines
there you go
[Music]
because once you start moving they might
start throwing kill oh you got to start
there
[Music]
Like A Champion
you probably will cry you better not
watch I'm telling you why
oh my goodness
all the time
oh come on
[Music]
you can't even make this stuff no you
can't
James not the king the king's pregame
routine was choked
[Music]
did he ever get it yeah I think it's
something I remember correctly
[Laughter]
his palms are sweaty shot weeks arms are
heavy ah oh
man
he was open
okay
that's funny
[Music]
[Applause]
Legend flashbacks
stop trying to be cute Luca looks like
he's racing dick pavetta oh my goodness
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's one way to use your assets
oh got him come on
come on Kessler
Josh Hart he's been balding too can
someone please give this man a high five
hey Jimmy you seen a guy named Lance
Kyle Lowry to the rescue
that's happened to him before happened
yeah
oh thank God
that is amazing I think he's late on the
high five he's late
like guys he's late number two Julius
Randle what happened to Julius what did
the five figure say to the face
smack smack
jaleness
stop shooting all my shots isn't that a
Dave Chappelle line what did the Bob
figure say this thing hey that's what he
said quit shooting all my shots
oh
Kenny your dog appeared there
momentarily oh my gosh and number one
Chuck wait he gave us some free advice
but we checked the receipts
can't hit somebody and run back
[Music]
somebody run back okay check the
receipts
[Music]
[Laughter]